Speaker 1: Let's continue our tour of this
weekend's 2024 Republican campaign happenings.
Ron DeSantis suffered another woke coma when
asked at the Roast and Ride event at which
Mike Pence also spoke.
We'll talk about Mike Pence's speech tomorrow.
I think we're just not going to have time
today.
This was in Des Moines, Iowa.
DeSantis went into a another one of these
comas where he uses the word woke.
I mean, let's count how many times he uses
it in 30 seconds.
Speaker 4: As president, I recognize that
the woke mind virus represents a war on the
truth.
So we will wage a war on the woke.
We will fight the woke in education.
We will fight the woke in the corporations.
We will fight the woke in the halls of Congress.
We will never, ever surrender to the woke
mob.
We will make woke ideology.
Leave it to the dustbin of history.
It's gone.
Speaker 1: So that's seven votes in the first
28 seconds there.
Now, has DeSantis ever defined woke?
He tried.
We're going to look at that a little bit later
when we also look at Nikki Haley's attempt.
I think the really what we'll talk about the
definition of woke a little bit later here.
What I want to mention, and it's particularly
important if we want to understand the DeSantis
campaign, the whole Anti-woke crusade that
the Santos is pushing is rooted in I'm not
going to say fascist ideology.
It's fascistic ideology which wants to silence
dissent and uphold whatever.
Right.
It used to be we silence dissent and uphold
white supremacy.
When you look to some prior fascists, it could
be for whatever reason.
At this point, we want to silence progressive
voices or we want to silence LGBT voices or
whatever.
And so he's using this fascistic fear mongering
and, of course, misinformation to demonize
those who challenge desantis's narrow and
extraordinarily biased view of what the world
and how the country is supposed to operate.
And so he will label any attempt to teach
or to learn about history and reality of racism
and oppression and all these things.
He will limit it.
That's what he does.
And of course, it completely ignores the educational
value, the cultural value of learning about
those things and of diversity and of inclusion.
He ignores the harm that these policies have
and the suppressive and oppressive impact
on speech that they push forward.
And so the dissent, this anti-woke obsession
is not only fascistic in its origins, I believe
it's also bad strategy because it doesn't
reflect the views or interests of even if
you don't want to say of most Americans, of
roughly half of Americans, according to recent
polls, a majority of Americans support teaching
about racism, support teaching slavery in
schools, oppose banning books that deal with
those issues.
A majority of Americans more than ever before
support LGBT rights and immigration reform
and voting rights.
All of that stuff is actually as popular or
more popular than any other positions on those
issues.
So the sand this ends up alienating himself
from mainstream public opinion and catering
to a fringe base that's driven by fear and
resentment and scapegoating and bigotry.
We know all this.
The question is, will obsessing about this
stuff allow DeSantis to appear to be a leader
rather than just a demagogue?
And if the voters of the Republican Party
want a demagogue, they've got their guy already,
and it's Trump.
So it's not particularly good strategy.
Toad Totally
a laughingstock, truly.